How would you compare?
So it seems like Elon Musk is more engineering centric,
but it's also, I think he considered himself a designer too.
He has a design mind. Steve jobs feels like he's much more ideas, space,
design space versus engineering. Yeah. Just make it happen.
Like the world should be this way. Just figure it out.
But he used computers, you know,
he had computer people talk to them all the time.
Like Mike was a really good computer guy. He knew computers.
Couldn't do computer, meaning computer hardware, like hardware, software,
all with pieces. And then he would, you know,
have an idea about what could we do with this next,
that was grounded in reality. It wasn't like he was, you know,
just finger painting on the wall and wishing somebody would interpret it. Like,
so he had this interesting connection because no,
he wasn't a computer architecture designer,
but he had an intuition from the computers we had to what could happen. And.
Essentially you say intuition because it seems like he was off a lot of
engineers in his intuition about what can and can't be done.
Those, the, like the,
what is all these stories about like floppy disc and all that kind of.
Yeah. So in, in Steve the first round,
like he'd go into a lab and look at what's going on and hate it and,
and, uh, fire people or, or ask somebody in the elevator,
what they're doing for Apple, not be happy when he came back.
My impression was is he surrounded himself with a relatively small group
of people and didn't really interact outside of that as much.
And then the joke was, you'd see, like somebody moving up,
prototype through the quad with a, with a black blanket over it.
And that was because it was secret, you know, partly from Steve.
Cause they didn't want Steve to see it until it was ready.
Johnny ive. And Steve is interesting. It's like, you don't want to,
he ruins as many ideas as he generates.
Yeah. Yeah. It's.
A dangerous kind of line to walk.
I don't know if you have a lot of ideas, like, uh,
Gordon bell was famous for ideas. Right.
And it wasn't that the percentage of good ideas was way higher than anybody
else. It was,
he had so many ideas and he was also good at talking to people about it and
getting into the filters. Right. And, you know, seeing through stuff.
Whereas Ilan was like, Hey, I want to build rockets.
So Steve was hire a bunch of rocket guys and Ilan would go read rocket manuals.
So better engineer that sense. Like, or like more, uh,
like a love and passion for the man.
Yeah. And the details.
Too. Right. Well, I guess you had craftsmanship to a bit of a different kind of.